all right I be welcome back so what's
going on in your life since last time
you were here it's been a month or so I
mean crazy [ __ ] that's a crazy [ __ ] yeah
I lost my dad I asked my daughter
you lost your daughter yeah that lost
them but she went to detail how did that
happen her grandmother called on me and
she basically told him that she felt
like I wasn't in the right space to take
care of my daughter so how do you feel
about that angry angry upset yeah do you
feel like you brought that on because of
the decisions you've made or oh yeah
how do you see it yeah I'm like my
decisions I guess so who's raising here
your daughter her grandparents program
plants are raised in here yeah there's a
chance if you got your life straightened
together you might get her back mm-hmm
yeah
mmm-hmm were you out with work now
you're still working
yeah nice wish I was but I mean I think
I've been depressed really so I don't
get up as much so as I really just sleep
yeah I believe this sleep a lot I asked
that question of pretty much all the
girls that come in that do what you do
and they all tell me they get depressed
from doing this it's not just you I
think I think everyone kind of tired
angry upset mm-hmm do you men
differently because of this the
interactions that you had a panic yeah
men man do you view men differently
because of this you know every no I view
a certain type of men differently that's
guys good do you see
yeah he's not all guys it's easier for
me to see people like I can't tell like
spirits by people I can give I like your
vibe I can tell if you were like a man
that raped me or I can catch on quickly
if you're just you know your intuition
must be very sharp yeah
do you talk with your daughter yeah I
see her I visit her and yeah video
caught her and stuff I just gave her
some clothes none today no a lot of your
siblings are in prison right yeah you
told me that last time
mm-hmm what do you think the chances are
of you getting out of this this
lifestyle and living yeah I mean I'm
either gonna do better I'm gonna die
like this
there's no no choices options I mean can
you can you imagine like in ten years
your daughter will be older you'll be
older and the decisions you make today
will really impact your your life
heavily I mean not now you're very young
still hallelujah 20 you're 20 you can
make a decision today they could change
yours and your daughter's life forever
yeah yeah there's programs that help me
yeah when some of it was the childhood
that you had and the tough breaks you
had early on so it's not like it's all
your fault
but still it's gonna be your job to
process all that and dig out of it yeah
so that's a tough topic to to hit on my
daughter's talked about suicide kind of
like that's hurtful what upsets you the
most about working the streets
it's what's the worst part of it what
upsets me the most is the min to take
advantage of us it comes with it I mean
yeah when we don't deserve it but but um
it's like why the [ __ ] like why would
you rape or robbed someone that's
already yeah that already has to do know
it has to but choose to do something
like this with their life it's
ridiculous that's what upsets me the
people that that take from us once
you're out there on the street
pretty much everyone sees you guys as
just something to be used yeah mm-hmm
nah
no one wants to hear your whole story
and how you got there and why and what
you're going through
oh no mos def you know knowing cuz it's
fun no one cares it's just what we're
here for and let's get it over with
because those the type of man a woman I
pay for a sex it's like that's obviously
something missing a name - yeah
everybody has something they feel the
void with so do you know do you have any
of your friends that do this that have
gotten out oh yeah I want to say friends
but I people you know yeah I've worked
with girls on the streets and I see them
like owning businesses now please do
they seem happier yeah fishing my fear
it still affects them in certain ways
they're still like takes it all and like
the way you do stuff the way you think
about stuff the way you see people
everything is money money money money
money do you think you're addicted to
the the fast money no there's nothing to
be addicted there's nothing to be
addicted to and I see your take - to
drugs or addicted to sex or the money is
there's way better money to make
goodness
way better
I'm personally I'm addicted to like
orientation cuz if I feel like I get out
of the lifestyle so I kind of like what
am I going back to really just my
daughter I'm gonna psyche my sister is
one mothers my brothers like I'm scared
of like losing a support system
basically we're not having a support
system when I want to get better it's
just like damn am I the only one I can
rely on it's kind of it's really scary
honestly it scares me hmm what scares
you the most only having myself to
depend on is scary like who do I call
them and I'm like almost there I'm ready
to give up I'm just gonna give up
I mean there are challenges like this
for everyone in life if you can have the
courage to decide make decisions for
yourself that are constructive that are
not destructive you can see you can
start seeing result and in terms of how
you feel about yourself and what your
quality of life is you may not make the
fast money that you're making but all
kinds of great things would come with it
I mean part of the problem might be that
nobody in your family or no one around
you is made those kind of decisions so
you don't have a whole lot of examples
of role models of how to do that
but just put you know put yourself and
your daughter's position and put
yourself at her head and imagine what
she would want she'll want her mom like
I wanted my mom exactly
it's kind of up to you to break the
cycle
hi I'm Stefan I just didn't expect to be
a mom so I release dad man am I ready
you're never gonna be ready you just do
it
all I can tell you is the easy way out
is never the way it's always gonna be
the hardest route that's gonna end up
being the right way that's across the
board the easy way the easy way won't
get you what you want
can you see yourself like 20 30 years
from now doing this because I've
interviewed girls that are 20 30 years
older than either so doing it I'll have
to do is look at my mom yeah there it is
there it is
so mmm
cuz I'm not I'm not going I'm not I
might be a little off but I'm not like
so way out to the point where there's no
return so it's like this is a battle
this is the choice yeah I mean what I
see in you is more than anything is just
your mood is so down that that must make
it hard for you to make good decisions
for yourself but if you can force
yourself to do that your mood might
improve and then it almost feeds on
itself in a positive way like one good
decision leads to another good decision
leads to feeling better about yourself
so it allows you to make more good
decisions and you can rebuild your life
and get your daughter back and live a
life that is everything he wanted it to
be maybe not the fast money of work in
the street that certainly safer more
respectful something that won't get you
depressed
something can lead to a relationship
because it couldn't be very hard for you
to have a relationship with a man who
knows that you're doing this maybe the
kind of guy you want
maybe yeah you can probably have a
relationship with a man but it won't be
the kind of relationship you want
yeah cuz yeah I get that a lot
I get that I'm like I'm kind of zoned
out but it's no maybes drugs and maybe
it is I'm tired of trying
[Music]
I think if you looked at what choices
you could make right now in your life
and figure out which one is the most
which one requires the most courage and
chose that one I think you could
probably change the direction of your
life really beautifully and the problem
is most people around you don't have the
courage to do anything like that they
just want to take the easy way out which
keeps them stuck and you probably feel
stuck yeah I feel like I've been stuck
since I was a kid that I guess it was
always kind of like this this shadow
does that follow me it's like I was
doing for it or something like yeah for
back like bad or evil I can follow me
courage is the way out of that yeah
maybe I got used to it I used to dude
like my shadow
I just sat with it but I can get out of
it it just tastes strange that's all
yep my darlin I wish you the best I hope
you figure this out cuz you're young and
you're beautiful and you're smart you
can do anything they're just gonna take
some hard work and courage and the
shortcuts and the fast life and all that
won't get you there
and maybe you never saw that because you
didn't have role models around it to
show you that but that's that's really
the way out
well my daughter yeah my daughter yeah I
mean you can you can use your daughter
as a reason to do this but really it's
yourself that you should use as a reason
to do this you know treat yourself as if
you're your daughter what would you do
for your daughter anything right you
should treat yourself that way too
you know how beautiful you are you're
the most beautiful girl I've had in here
you really are do you see yourself that
way
are you cool mm-hm
I'm pretty yes you are
just don't rely on that rely on your
courage and your strength
[Music]
you
you